Yeah a lot of people have written me
about this FartGate on "Hardball" last
night there was an obvious fart and
Chris Matthews is calling it fake news.
He says it was his cup running against
the the the desk there's no fucking way
People are experts, experts in sports and they're
on TV, people are experts in the stock
market. I'm an expert in farting I know
when it's a fart and this was a fart. It
was a fart it's not a cup and I can even
prove it I'll do an experiment. First listen to the tape, Robin.
That's a little fashion-forward. Here's a mug, the Jeff the Drunk
"Chello" mug as you can see and I
have a similar surface here to the desk at MSNBC.
How do you know that?
Because I watch that show every night and it's a
sleek, slick, surface. That's how I know.
You don't know where that cup was.
It could have been sitting on a mat.
Look, this is what a cup sounds like on a
surface like that. You hear that? Listen
Robin.
You don't even know if it's the right
kind of mug.
Yeah no because they have a
"Chello" mug on the set. That's what a mug sounds like.
Your science is specious.
Let's go back to the tape.
I'm a fart scholar I've studied farting
since I don't know, college?
But you don't have the exact material. You can't sneak a fart pass Howard Stern and what's with
all this shame and embarrassment. Stop
it, do what I do, make it part of the show.